[Música]
un tren de 150 vagones de los cuales 20
tenían componentes peligrosos se
descarriló el 3 de febrero en Ohio
Estados Unidos como ya lo hemos contado
aquí en France 24 Esto ocurrió
concretamente en la población de varios
de los productos químicos que
transportaba la compañía
norfoldrenway se derramaron y esto
generó un incendio las autoridades
respondieron evacuando el contenido de
cinco vagones que llevaban cloruro de
vinilo y lo quemaron controladamente el
resultado fue una nube de humo negro
luego comenzaron a aparecer gallinas y
más de 3.500 peces muertos el jueves el
administrador de la agencia de
protección Ambiental de Estados Unidos
Michael visitó la zona y Desde allí
reiteró la postura de las autoridades
que no han encontrado Rastros de
contaminación ni en el agua ni en el
aire pero los habitantes hablan de falta
de transparencia en la información y no
confían que su salud esté segura en el
lugar para hablar del tema nos acompaña
desde México Benjamín Ruiz él es experto
en Materiales peligrosos y un químico
con bastante experiencia Gracias
Benjamín por estar con nosotros
empecemos por hablar de qué es el
cloruro de vinilo Y qué tan contaminante
es para la salud de los humanos
el cloruro de vinilo es un gas que tiene
como características ser muy inflamable
y con un alto índice de exclusividad
es la materia prima para fabricar el
famoso PVC el plástico conocido como PVC
Entonces cuando se descarrila el tren y
algunos de los contenedores se rompen
siendo un gas y siendo transportado como
líquido comprimido inmediatamente
empieza a fugar
la propia fricción entre el gas y la
atmósfera provoca que se incendie y esto
a pesar de lo aparatoso que pueda hacer
es
la mejor opción porque si no se
incendiara se iría acumulando y al
mezclarse con el oxígeno del aire
provocaría una explosión de
magnitudes incalculables Entonces hasta
el momento con todo lo aparatoso que es
el incendio con todo lo aparatoso que es
el humo negro que se está emitiendo es
la mejor opción para el derrame
ahora bien es un gas más pesado que el
aire y se deposita entonces a nivel de
la superficie es decir al nivel de piso
esa es una de las razones por las cuales
se han encontrado animales muertos tanto
en tierra como en agua por qué Porque
desplaza al oxígeno desplaza al aire y
los peces Entonces ya no hay el
intercambio de oxígeno entre agua y aire
y los peces empiezan a morir asfixiados
igual que las gallinas y en esta Y
discúlpame que lo interrumpa en esta
combinación del oxígeno del aire y este
gas que es el cloruro de vinilo Cuáles
son los impactos que pueden padecer los
humanos
el problema principal es que si los
humanos permanecen en la zona
el oxígeno va siendo desplazado y los
humanos empiezan a sentir síntomas de
asfixia y pueden morir asfixiados esa es
la razón por la cual se tuvo que evacuar
una gran zona alrededor de el sitio del
percance no solamente por el riesgo del
fuego sino porque al seguirse liberando
algo de cloruro de vinilo este puede
llegar a provocar asfixia obviamente
la gente que esté expuesta va a tener
problemas como dolor de cabeza
ardor de ojos ardor de garganta es
sentirse en general mal
pero es una consecuencia es una
consecuencia lógica y que no es de largo
plazo excepto en quienes tengan
problemas respiratorios crónicos por
ejemplo personas que tengan asma pues va
a ser eh mucho más fuerte el episodio de
asma o más frecuentes los episodios de
asma que puedan estar sufriendo
Sí hay un impacto ambiental desde luego
es eso es obvio hay un aumento en la
cantidad de
CO2 que se emite a la atmósfera una
parte del Cloruro de vinilo por la
velocidad con que está saliendo de los
contenedores se va al ambiente
permanece algún tiempo pero en general
es una enorme exageración hablar de
chernóbil dos porque como bien se dice
aquí no hay material radioactivo
Entonces lo interrumpo de nuevo no hay
material radioactivo como usted dice y
es una exageración hablar de lo que está
pasando en Ohio es un chernóbil Dos
punto cero hay otros productos químicos
que fueron liberados por este
descarrilamiento como el acrilato de
epixelicio El isobutileno o el acrilato
de butilo que son estos componentes y
son o no contaminantes más o menos que
el cloruro de vinilo
los acrilatos Son compuestos que se
pueden utilizar como materia prima para
hacer adhesivos conocidos Como
poliacrilatos
y el butileno es un material que se
puede utilizar para la fabricación de
Hules sintético casi todos son materias
primas para la industria de los
plásticos
el mismo problema se puede se puede
esperar que haya
un alto índice de explosividad y que
entonces convenga que se estén quemando
con todo lo malo que puede tener el
hecho de que tengamos un incendio
aparatoso es más
adecuado permitir que se siga quemando a
apagar el incendio y que se siga
liberando el material sin quemar porque
entonces podemos provocar una explosión
entonces de los males hay que buscar el
menor de ellos y es lo que se está
haciendo desde mi punto de vista
muy correctamente y hablando
precisamente de lo que usted dice que se
debe Buscar el menos peor de los males
Le quiero preguntar cómo se deben
transportar estos componentes químicos y
si es o no entre el cual sería el mal
menos peor para poder transportar estos
productos
yo creo que utilizar trenes con tantos
vagones
implica un riesgo alto porque cada vagón
Debería de ir acompañado con un equipo
de personal entrenado para
atender cualquier emergencia con el
contenido de los vagones cada sustancia
debe ir acompañada con lo que se conoce
como
msds material
que tienen toda la información de qué es
lo que puede hacer qué es lo que puede
suceder Cuáles son las instrucciones
para tratar un derrame una fuga un
incendio
para tratar a las personas que han sido
afectadas tanto a nivel piel como a
nivel respiratorio como a nivel de
ingesta a través del del aparato
digestivo
esos trenes no llevan esa cantidad de
personal claro precisamente reducen
personal y por eso aumenta el número de
carros Yo creo que es un es un error de
logística que sí baja costos pero
aumenta incrementa los riesgos